my favorite ram is on the phone marshall
faulk hi marshall
hi susie did you hear me call you my
favorite ram
just making sure i heard that i heard it
means a lot to me
it does right really does yeah i figured
it's nice i know where my bread is
buttered
hi marshall uh marshall
question for you did you see the crazy
press conference at all i sent you a
couple clips i'm sure that you saw
aaron rodgers unpacking in green bay he
came in yesterday looking a little bit
like blade runner with his hair in a man
bun
a chill kevin shirt on flip-flops a
backpack
and today he unloaded a whole lot of
cerebral eren
in green bay what do you make of what's
going on there
but i think they made up and they don't
want to tell us you know it's like
it's like you don't want to tell your
friend when the girlfriend
you broke up with and said you weren't
going to get back with her and you do
and you don't know how to tell your
friend so you
you you just you just you say a bunch of
stuff and that's what this sounded like
today
um
i i just if it's not personnel then what
is it i
just want to know what else affects it
affects him doing his job
and at this point hasn't he earned the
right
to be in the conversation there's no
packer quarterback who's been there
longer this is the 17th season
he is who he is hasn't he earned the
right to be in the conversation
oh without a doubt without a doubt i
mean he
i i think so um and the
the thing about it is uh
why wasn't he like who doesn't ask
the quarterback like your quarterback
older than your head coach
[Laughter]
i just it just blows my mind and um
these are the problems these are the
problems in the decisions and and uh
i'm gonna say this obviously
i think the last two guys that that's
left that that just has carte blanche to
do this kind of stuff
is you know belichick um and uh
and greg popovich in sports i don't
think anybody else can pull these kind
of stunts
when you look at what's happened with
them two with kawhi leonard wanting to
leave san antonio
and then tom brady leaving and going to
win in tampa
it's like people are questioning you
know because
we're not talking about we're not
talking about the the
the spurs in the playoffs right now
we're just not
and and last year you know we'll we'll
see because
we want to get some different stuff you
just have to handle it different
and i don't know i don't i just i just
felt like green bay was always a
functional organization
we never heard these kind of things
coming out of green bay
and here we are i blame it on the
shareholders mike deltufo is a
shareholder for green bay so i think
it's just bad management
and bad shareholding
i call that dell two for del two though
two four you were proud of like
you were you were like oh what exactly
when adam when schefter broke that story
i mean
i was like it was like it was like you
were hearing a lie
it was the first time that adam broke a
story i was like adam's
lying cause it seems ridiculous
it seems ridiculous exactly
i mean adam adam breaks a lot of stories
and and i'm like oh man there's
stephanie
this one i was like he's lying it just
it was
it was unbelievable yeah marshall
marshall what do you think about
rich has been on this too about uh the
tom brady effect that like tom brady
basically saying i'm out i'm leaving new
england and then doing it his way
going to tampa them accommodating him in
basically bringing in his friends gronk
and leonard fournette and antonio brown
and then they won a super bowl and then
all these other quarterbacks rogers
russell wilson looked at that and went
huh why can't we do that here i want
some of that
yeah well well i'm gonna say this i'm
gonna say more than anything
i'm gonna put it just to add a little
twist to it
it was the fact that although tom
still wanted to play new england
wasn't they were not like okay let's do
it tom's way
after all that he had done and if i'm
looking i'm like okay he's won this many
super bowls
i've won this many hold on wait they got
rid of far
for me i gotta get out of here right
i gotta go somewhere where they're gonna
let me kind of have some say
and and the reality is that's what he's
looking for he's looking for more say
now
whether whether he's going to have that
i don't know
it's it's it's tough man and and players
are players are starting to understand
the dynamic of of the power that they
have
in the game and let me say that the
quarterback because of how much they're
paying them
and how we have put we have put so much
onus
on the position to where i mean they
control the game
they literally control the game marshall
the power shifted and it keeps shifting
in the national football league devante
adams
was asked today if he would take a
discount
if rogers is back in 2022 he said that's
not going to happen what other
profession do you see
where you take less than what you've
been earned i've earned the right to be
paid the highest in the league if
somebody had asked
you to take a discount what would oh god
what would you have said to them
marshall falk
hey man listen i took discounts
from from my last year in college
all the way down to when i played little
league all that was discount
you got to see free football when it's
time to get paid it's time to get paid
that's right i'm talking about no
discount go walk go walk
go walk into nema marcus and ask an
astor discount
[Laughter]
yeah go go try that go you walk in the
sacks and that's for a discount they're
gonna send you the off stacks with
averages
they got a whole difference they don't
even do this they got a whole different
store
if you want a discount that's that's
what i'm talking about it's you know you
don't do that
it's just why did you put in the work
why did you put it in work you know
it's bananas this game is man it's it's
it's amazing
it's amazing it's amazing that who they
pull that clap with
right that's that's the thing that gets
me
it's amazing at who they pull that crap
with like i was just thinking like
okay so matthew stafford just went to a
better team
with a better coach in the better
situation
did he take less money
well the price of living is very high in
malibu we can't ask him to take it
cut listen he's been balling over budget
for a long time let's be real
right now now now you get you get on a
better team
you should have went in and say hey you
guys want 10 million yeah
yeah give me money back yeah who you got
you guys want to get julio jones i can
give you a kid
we can we are he should have been doing
anything
but we don't we just we just don't we
just don't ask that
from the position i mean it's just
it's it's i i just don't i don't get it
i don't get it yeah and you would think
green bay knowing aaron
it's his 17th year with the team like
they know his personality they had to
have known
this wasn't going to fly with him but
let's hold away
let's just let's just say this and
nobody said this because
the totality we're thinking about aaron
rodgers leaving
like that's what we're thinking about
hey
aaron rodgers played awful in the game
they lost because of his interception
yeah no doubt i'm just saying
and normally when they lose it's not his
fault right
it's just not his fault it's it's not
it's like the offensive line or this or
that
you know or defense couldn't stop nobody
but i i'm just going
like tom brady i'll play them well it
wasn't aaron's
decision to kick a field goal either
well it was aaron's reason why they were
kicking the field goal
well he didn't run it in i guess
hey i'm just listening man we play the
game we
we play the game you you open yourself
up for everything you know it's like
all right these decisions need to be
made and the questions got to be asked
are you surprised are you surprised that
he showed up are you surprised that
aaron's back
that's a lot of money on the table like
when people
talking about oh yeah he's gonna sit out
it's a lot of money on the table
i don't care what you say like you
should you show up to camp and don't do
nothing
but you don't not show up that's a lot
of money
because there was the check that he
would have to write i mean it started
with a 30.
i mean that's a that's a check if he'd
sat out i mean that's a that's a lot of
coin
yep um you know
and here's the thing where
else um
where else like he he didn't have a
destination
like it's not like he had a place he
could go
he just didn't have that he doesn't have
it
some stuff has to happen for for things
to happen his way
i mean if they hadn't drafted trade
lance i in san francisco would be a lock
maybe they still are to give that kid
what a couple years to maybe sit behind
him
maybe next year who knows
and also marshall you're a business guy
a team
has to draft a good quarterback you have
to have a plan
it doesn't always have to be personal
does it
exactly exactly it it doesn't
it doesn't but but i but but i'm i'm
going to assume
that he asked questions and they told
him
mind your business
and they didn't give him the answers
that he wanted
because he's a level-headed guy this is
not you know he
and that that's when
you know when the comments started
coming out
fascinating you know obviously
you know cash moves everything around me
he's in camp pro football hall of famer
marshall falk joins us here on the rich
eisen show susie schuster in for rich
marshall curious on your thoughts on
simone biles we've had
more calls today than i can remember
people want to opine on her what's your
thought as a professional athlete
looking at
this 24 year old with the weight of the
world on her shoulders
saying that she had to step away
well here's here's what i'm going to say
all right
and i know nobody you know the people
are not going to like this and they
don't hear anything
um we as professional athletes
let's just say things aren't going right
normally it was just like we were
nervous we were scared
but now we have this this you know i'm a
step away mentally i'm not ready
and and there's that there's a mentally
something wrong and mentally i'm not
ready
i don't think they're the same thing and
we don't know what it is we don't know i
mean it could be serious
i mean naomi osaki she lost in the
olympics it was like wow man that's how
i play that bad
you know but we have to we we have to
give
athletes space to all to and understand
that we
go through things mentally as well but
as athletes we also have to understand
that
you know let's not let's not
let's not use that in a sense as a
potential out when
we may be not at our best
so people can't take shots at us or say
things or question
and and that's the dynamic that we're in
now when you look at it it's like
because if if you don't want to give any
announcement
analysis on it because if something's
mentally wrong with her which we'll
never find out
you don't want to be the person who
people come after
but just looking at it from both sides
athlete's side
being the person who played high
pressure situations and
i've stunk it up before man if i could
have just said
you know i'm gonna take yeah we we lost
the super bowl because i fumbled and i
didn't play well
yeah i'm gonna take the next month or
two off and and like get my mental
health right yeah my mental health was
messed up after
after we lost
you know it's it's sensitive it's very
sensitive
and and and everybody you know where
we're at and today is where everybody
steps away from it you know and you have
to you have to respect
where where the athlete may very well be
but as an analyst you still do your job
and and give your opinion about it
and understand that you're not you're
not
condoning you're just hey here's the
other side of it
like i said i wish when i played bad i
could have
i had something to say other than i
stuck it up
what was it like for you marshall since
you brought it up
i mean just it's just a bad you lose
you lose games or big games and you
don't get the job done
i mean you're searching you're mentally
searching for okay what's wrong with me
i mean i remember uh like my maybe third
or fourth year in indy
um i just i i was in a little bit of a
[ __ ]
and i don't know maybe maybe maybe it
was a mental thing i don't know
you know i have no idea if that's what
it was but
i know i wasn't you know as um
clear-minded and you know and and i
think that's the
we don't you know that that that's that
tough mentality
and we're like hey just get help seek
help
find somebody to help you work through
this uh
because later in life it could help you
so but
and i think we ever everybody goes
through it everybody goes through it
and i just think now people are more
more vocal about it
trying to help others i just want to
make sure
you know a reporter or somebody is like
going in on somebody asking because this
this person
is is kind of arrogant about their game
and always doing well and
something happens and then you're asking
them okay what happened what's going on
and they
and they dropped the mental health issue
on you you got to kind of let up now
i think there's got to go next subject
or something
i think there's so much pushback because
people seem to feel
that athletes are hiding behind it as if
it's an excuse
but those are people who've never played
the game or done a double flip into a
triple twisting double back
exactly and listen it's high pressure
it's a lot and and just i
just just going from last olympics to
this olympics
and and then you then you get put on
hold for a year
i mean this this young lady she's
listen uh i'm gonna say this um
high pressure intense situation is not
like she's not like
us she don't get gains every week and
then another season i mean it's every
four years
you got to be great you got to be your
best
and um yeah i just and i
i feel for her and uh because so much
was expected
of her coming in i mean i i i saw her in
commercials
my gosh man the most commercials
i've ever seen somebody in over the past
year maybe two years
and rightfully deserved and there's a
lot of pressure that comes with that
marshall falk here on the rich eisen
show susie schuster in for rich
before we let you go marshall and thank
you thanks again for your time
let's go a little light we need a little
light it's been a heavy wednesday
marshall
so in the last segment we talked about
sugar cereal there you go i just made
the turn
because we have to because you know what
this is such a heavy subject matter
that it can bring us all down and it's
it's worth talking about
but at the end of the day we have to all
as i keep saying throughout this entire
show
compassion until you get off the couch
until you try that yourself
compassion try it it doesn't hurt anger
isn't great
but we have to find levity or else we'll
drive ourselves crazy
so we talk so let me ask you what's your
favorite sugar cereal marshall because
we need to we need to laugh a little bit
yeah um my favorite sugar cereal now
uh it's a toss-up between um
honey smacks and uh captain crunch berry
oh crunch berry so i'm like yeah i can
like like those two
you know they um i'm torn
i i never know which way to go right do
you ever mix them together
no no purist yeah purist
purest that would mess up that would
mess up my milk because you know the
flavor of milk
afterwards is like the best exactly tj
see
yeah marshall knows yeah you got to
drink the milk marshall
right you got it yeah
do you go do you go full cow or or do
you go to ramen
um you know i'm a lactate kind of guy
you know yeah i'm a lactate kind of guy
so when i serve you for thanksgiving and
i make mashed potatoes do i have to use
like a a
lactaid free or a lactose free butter
for the mashed potatoes that i won't
buy um by anyway who am i kidding nah
i'm okay with whatever you make it with
i'll just blow up your bathroom later
okay marshall real quick real quick now
that we're laughing
we were on a night we were on a 2000s
rap video
kick the other day and notice that you
and big game and demarco far in the air
force ones video can you just like
quickly tell us how that came about and
if there are any crazy stories
of that day um
yeah the stories were very crazy me and
nelly were still friends will continue
to be friends but i'm not telling them
to you guys but it was
fun we had a really good time
and that was back in the day when like
videos was videos and
making like real videos and um on set
was
man
by the way nothing makes me laugh like a
poop joke is that wrong
i mean that's like i mean do i have
airplane humor i'm like a 12 year old
he said blow it up i think that's the
that's kind of what took it to the next
i know i'm a little scared of that right
now
we'll have to get the air force one
videos uh next time
marshall miss you i miss you guys
y'all have a good one thank you for
having me appreciate it
be good brother talk soon that's the
great marshall faulk it's not a hall of
famer for nothing
the best don't ask him to take a
discount we just learned that lesson
absolutely not yeah hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here